Voice winner Jordan Smith is officially  a married man ET can confirmed that the  22 year old singer weds his longtime  girlfriend christened any Saturday in  Kentucky the newlyweds exchange nuptials  at a church surrounded by close friends  and family the bride posted a priceless  Instagram photo of the couple sharing  their first smooch at the altar in the  caption she wrote best day ever  hashtag officially mr. and mrs. Smith  mr. and mrs. Smith shared in a statement  to ET quote our wedding has reminded us  that we are just two best friends who  realized were both the same kind of  crazy and fell in love  Jordan popped the question on New Year's  Day in Boston I was very surprised I  wasn't expecting it at all  et caught up with the pair back in  February where the singer spilled on how  he pulled off the romantic proposal I  kind of just know her like the back of  my hand so I did it all myself and  figured everything out thank God it  turns out it turned out okay she liked